[Music]
you
hello we're back again with this session
on perception now in the last session we
looked at some models of bottom-up
processing where we define perception
through a data-driven process so
bottom-up processes actually help in
perception or predict perception by
looking at how perception gets built
from stimulus single stabilized and
addition of the single stabilized gives
rise to the perception another modular
perception which is prevalent in
cognitive psychology is the top-down
model of perception now at the beginning
of this lecture I gave you the
difference between what is the top-down
and the bottom-up process of perception
the turbulent process is a theory
deviant process where expectations of
people generate perception whereas the
bottom-up process is a data-driven
process where characteristics of the
stimuli certain features of the stimuli
lead to whatever perception we are
looking for or whatever percept or the
meaning that we are generating from the
stimulus which is coming from sensation
so let's begin a study of the top-down
processes of perception the top-down
process of perception also are also
called the theory driven or conceptually
driven process of perceptions here
expectations of the perceiver is the
main responsible feature for the
development of meaning or the
development of percept from the
sensations
chapathis turn through the visual system
so the whole process of perception right
from the meaning of the percept to
pattern recognition has on the back side
or on behind these processes the
expectation of the viewer look at this
le way the same thing that we saw in
model R in the first model of bottom-up
processing now they're the explanation
of this visual scene was given in terms
of the structure of the le way in terms
of the shading the light which is
falling on this le way the kind of
windows it has the kind of background it
has and all those features combined
together gave a meaning of what this
picture depicted in the top-down process
we again look at the same elevate and we
try to explain the meaning that is
generated through the top-down process
to things that are evident that are
really the main frame or the backbone of
the top-down process is the expectancy
effect and the context effect so
basically the context effect the effect
of context in which a perception is is
made and the expectancy of the viewer
are responsible for the top-down process
so coming back to the explanation of
this visual scene using the top-down
process this visual scene is explained
in terms of memory or in in terms of the
idea that people would have viewed a
structure similar to this or maybe this
particular structures on there so
basically in terms of in in terms of the
top-down process the experience that are
this is an archway with margulies comes
from the fact that you expect
certain kind of certain kind of visual
features a certain kind of objects in
the visual field based on your memory
based on your previous experience with
visual scene like this which you have
seen in the real world as I said the two
factors which the bottom-up process
cannot explain in terms of perception
are expectancy effect in context effect
let's look at context effect let's look
at the figure on the top as you can see
if I ask you the question whether the
size of the middle ball the ball or the
circle at the middle of what the figures
are the same and most people would
actually get up with this answer that
they are not same but amazingly the size
of both the balls are both the circles
which are in the middle of the black
circle is same the reason being that the
one on the Left has bigger balls and in
the context of that it appears the
circle in the middle is smaller in size
whereas it is not and on the right since
he has smaller balls surrounding the
circle it seems to be different and so
context where an object is in the
environment has a lot to do with
perception similarly the figure on your
right if I show this figure most people
would go ahead and read this figure and
the actual meaning of this figure would
be wonders of perception now amazingly
word wonders of perception is not clear
but what really happens is the brain
sees that or from your past experiences
you see that this is the most plausible
this is the most plausible answer which
is out there and so one does the
perception is being is being interpreted
because you expect the brain expects and
and the brain sees this this particular
idea that it should be wonders of
perception also since this is a class of
perception so we do see the bottom half
of this figure to be meaning perception
because the context in which we are
studying is perception and so
should be wonders the perception and so
these are the two figures are these are
two examples of how perception
progresses or meaning of perception is
done through the top-down model the
context in which a pattern or object
appears apparently sets up certain
expectations in the perceiver as to what
objects will occur know both accuracy
and the length of time needed to
recognize an object vary with the
context so the more complex the context
the more time it will require for
somebody to go ahead and make the
meaning of the perception now elegant
and computational model of top-down
process of perception was given by David
Marr now what this Mars theory or mass
idea is that the model of perception
proceeds Bekins perception proceeds by
constructing mental representations or
mental schemas no perception Mars
beliefs is a special-purpose
computational mechanism which progresses
through certain modules and these
modules are the module for analyzing
color the module for analyzing motion
the module for analyzing shading and
this part of the theory or this part of
his idea is the bottom-up process he
further says that with these modules the
modules for basic information about the
stimulus combines with the module for
expectancy and context and that
generates perception so in in brief
Davis Marr model is basically a model
which combines both bottom-up and
top-down processes to explain perception
what David Marr believes that visual
perception is are actually mental
representation or mental sketches based
on three kind of representations which
exists within the observer within the
person who's perceiving now there are
three steps to it there are three
different steps to it when you perceive
something when somebody sub peers
perceive something the first step takes
place and this is called a perceptual or
the primal sketch
in the primal sketch depicts our from
eight from the final sketch one can get
information related to the relative
brightness and darkness to the images
localized geometric structures and
boundary conditions so this kind of a
basic information is related to the
two-dimensional world related to the
basic brightness and darkness and
geometrical structures as what what is
gathered up from the primal sketch so
according to Davis math model perception
progresses through a complete through a
list of steps even the first step the
primal sketch is made and this primal
sketch is actually a two dimensional
model or a two dimensional percept which
has information on to it relate relating
to brightnesses and darkness and
geometric structures now once an which
which basically helps people in
detecting boundaries between objects and
figures within figures and backgrounds
now once the primary sketch or the
primal sketch is ready the next step is
constructing a to an Hardy sketch now in
the two and a half D sketch using cues
from the environment again so both step
one the primal sketch and two and a half
D sketch are actually the bottom-up
processes of perception or the bottom a
part of perception which this model goes
ahead and explains so the first two
steps actually uses the data from the
stimuli so into an hearty sketch what
really happens is that shading in
texture and other information for
example surfaces and relative depth are
gathered from the environment or from
the environmental cues onto the percept
and that gives an idea about where the
object is in the environment where the
localization of the object and and the
kind of object it seems to be so the
first to step in Mars mass's theory of
perception are bottom-up process once a
two and a half D sketch is made at the
point when this sketch is complete
viewers
have an idea of where the object is what
does it look like what are the basic
features of this object what are the
basic characteristics like the color the
shape the shading the boundaries the
brightness the darkness those kind of
informations get available to the visual
processing area once these two steps are
complete a third and final step called
the final 3d sketch is produced where
recognition of an object is made in
terms of the in in terms of the context
and expectation here the meaning of the
visual scheme and the recognition of
object is made and this happens through
a top-down process
so basically Mars model combines both
the top-down process and the bottom-up
process for making any kind of percept
and in very simple words what his model
suggests is during the primal sketch and
a two and half D Sketch information
relating to stimuli from basic 2d
information to some sort of two and a
half the information which is related to
shading localization of object in the
world
depth perception relative depths are
gathered in the final step of his
process which is a top-down process
which is a top-down method what really
happens is that viewers expectation and
memory come into play and leads people
to perceive to make a final percept to
make a final recognition of out of the
object in front of him of other object
is and this information is derived from
memory now some examples of how this
top-down process really works I'm going
to relate now one of the best examples
of or one of the best example of the
top-down process is something called
perceptual learn if you look at the
figure on the right side when you look
it for the first time you won't be able
to see anything but as you move along as
you go ahead and see it time after time
for multiple times what starts to emerge
is a figure of a person and
happens because as you keep on seeing it
a number of times some meaning is
generated out of it
so what perceptual learning really means
is that perception changes with practice
as as we go on practicing as we go ahead
and practice a lot what really happens
is that we are able to generate
perception now very recent experiment
was done by Gibson to prove perceptual
learning what Gibson really did was he
did an experiment a very simple
experiment in which a coil like this was
given to subjects this kind of coil was
shown to subjects what subjects were
required to do is to remember this later
on subjects are shown for different
coils of this type but these have
different orientations so this kind of
coils so this is my basic coil and these
coils which differ from the basic coil
in some or the other way in terms of
orientations in the term of number of
coils in the term of where the starting
point is were shown to people later and
and they were asked to report whether
these four coils how many of these four
coils actually matched the basic white
later on a number of different coils
with different different orientations
were shown two subjects
and they were asked and within this this
whole picture was hidden for different
four versions of the initial basic point
and subjects were asked to reproduce how
many times times did they actually go
how many copies of the original coil was
available now it was seen as that with
number of practices that the increase in
the number of practices subject starts
making less and less error and when
feedback was taken from subject what
happened is most subjects related to the
fact that as they kept on practicing as
they kept on seeing the basic coil and
practicing it they started learning that
all started observing those features of
the stimulus which they didn't see it at
the time at the first time so as they
came familiar became familiar with the
subjects more and more they started
noticing parts of the stimulus which
they had not noticed on the first advent
and then the first interaction with the
stimulus so this is an interesting
feature or this is an interesting I'd
say an example of top-down process where
what happens is that the more number of
times you interact with something the
more features you'd see and the your
expectations are developed accordingly
and more easier the learning becomes
another interesting thing or another
interesting example of top-down process
of learning of perceptual learning is
something called change blindness now it
is the inability to detect changes in
objects or seen especially when given
different views of that object
so basically if something is shown to
you and many versions are many different
versions of this particular object is
shown to you from different different
angles people are not able to they take
this gene and this is what is called
change blindness now look at the figure
which is on your left and you would see
that one of the person right here
changes but if I don't tell you this
that this is going to change you will
not be able to
similarly if you look at the figure here
what happens is the person at the back
of the back of the screen will change
but if I don't advise you or if I don't
give you this clue that is going to
change if you don't expect it it's not
going to change now change blindness is
a direct example is one of the best
example to show that the brain sees what
it wants to see an expectation place a
lot of role into into perception we have
seen a lot of movies and so what really
happens is that often you would have
found that in movies there are scenes
which are inconsistent with the movie
and no matter how many times the editor
cuts it so there are parts of the movies
we still remain but most people do not
see these deviations in the scene these
deviations in the movie example in one
movie in one scene there was a white was
and in in in a next scene the wasps
disappeared and this was quite quite
funny but the thing is that this was
this particular thing was not edited I
mean there was got away or the what
waswas not sewn in the second scene
whereas the third scene the wash
reappeared and so somehow the editor who
was reading the movie forgot this and
people since when they were watching the
movie they were actually worth watching
the gist of the movie so they they had
in a certain expectation and since this
was which was there in front of them it
was not in their expectation or they
were not expecting it or they didn't see
that much so they couldn't notice this
change and so change blindness is
another interesting feature of the
top-down process another interesting
example of the top-down process is
something called the word security
effect look at the word which is given
to you on the right what is this word it
seems like the word is wo RR but it is
not as most people if I give
- right those people who know the
English and most people who are literate
if I give them they'll say it is wo RK
now since this part that you are seeing
is covered by a black spot and so
expectation believes that since wo RR is
no word and people will not go ahead and
write and so this is since I'm talking
about word security this has to be a
word and it has to be work and so that
that is another interesting phenomena
what security effect is another
interesting phenomena which suggests or
supports the idea that top-down
processes of perception exist
now interesting experiment was done to
test word security effect so here what
happened is people were shown interface
like this
in which the letter K or D was presented
to them for very brief periods of time
and later on they were tested the letter
K and D was presented to them and they
were tested in the sense that whether or
in which context
do they
are they able to unto identify this KND
so the experiment ran in this way
initially they were letter K or D was
present to people for a very brief
period of time later on they were shown
this kind of three different segments in
which in the first segment the blank
side was represented and in the slide
there were a single letter K or D
written on it and people were asked to
recall back whether K or D was presented
in the second case a word was written a
part of the word for example the blue or
was eaten and this D or K was presented
to people and they were asked to report
that whether D or K the whether D or K
was presented in the initial design and
later on unknown word was presented to
them and it was asked whether the D or K
occurred in my presentation slide and
interestingly it was found out that when
this D or K was presented in the context
of a word it was produced or more less
number of errors are generated by
participants which means that in the
context of a word perception is easy
another interesting feature or example
of what security if effect or top-down
processes of perception is something
called the connectivist model of word
perception now what this model says is
that first the perception of word
actually goes through or progresses
through several stages whether it is
word or whether it is a sound which is
perceived the perception happens to
several stages and these stages can be
either excitatory or inhibitory for
example what perception starts at the
level of features where at the first
step the features of the word for
example whether it is a curved line
whether it is a slanted line whether it
is a dashed line a circle is presented
at or is part of the word is first
perceived and from here from the
level it goes to the little or the level
of letters here these features are
combined together to form individual
letters for example ACK and so on and so
forth and at a higher level there is a
word level where the actual word is
basically being presented so this kind
of perception really takes place now
what is the what is the reason or what
is the meaning of all this it basically
says that from the feature level to the
letter level a lesser number of
connections are there whereas from the
letter level to the word level more
number of Corrections are there and so
what really happens is if the perception
happens of the word level it's easier
for people to perceive letters it are
then when it is at the level of features
what really it says is that perception
of a word the activation of relevant
node for a word activates the node
correspond to the letter within the word
thereby facilitating their perception so
for example if it is able that I'm
looking at if a word is able that I have
to see what happens is this kind of
connections start this kind of this is
the feature level so the first
identification of first perception is
the bottom of process process this
starts at this level and from there this
is called the letter level here this is
integrated together so for example if I
am looking for a the word a which is not
present here so ble is presented to you
a is not presented and if I am looking
at whether a a is presented or a it
should be the word here or not and if a
is presented to you what really happens
is that these all these features are
evaluated now since a doesn't has this
feature so this connection from here to
here is an average reconnection whereas
since this is present in a this is an
excitatory connections and so since
these with these many features a number
of letters can actually be generated for
example a and T GC and so what happens
is for each of it we will have an
excitatory or inhibitory connections so
those connections
which suggests that this is the part of
the word that you're looking at or part
of the feature of the word that you're
looking at is is is present will be
excitatory connections in part of the
word which is not for example this is
something which is not present in a and
so these connections from here will be
inhibitory similarly from these letters
the on on this word so if a is not
present a is the most apt answer here
example n ble is not a word and so a is
the most possible answer T ble is
another no word and so T is not a fit
here G ble is no word and so G is not
fit here and SB le is another no word
so basically the only word which is
available in this case is a and so a is
the only perception which happens and so
this happens to expectation so at this
level the first if the perception
happens from this level it is generally
a top-down process and if the perception
happens from this level of it is
generally the bottom-up process and so
what mainly top-down process suggests is
that it is not only the stimulus
features of the words that helps us in
perception the word perception progress
is not only through basic features of
the word it also progresses through
something called the level of
expectation that is why when we actually
lead in terms of reading when we are
eating something even if some word or
meaning of word is not clear to us based
on the context on where the word is we
generate the meaning and we are able to
understand the meaning of the sentence
and so this is this is an expectancy
effect where what happens is the context
in which the word is presented where it
appears gives us a meaning of that word
or some Greek meaning of this word so
this is the top-down process of
perception where what we actually looked
at those features of the word are those
parts of the word where where perception
happens through people's expectation and
context effect in what context award is
presented what is the expectation of
people that helps us in
the overall perception another
interesting theory which was given or
which was proposed by someone called JJ
Gibson is called direct perception now
it is an interesting theory of
perception which says that the user
doesn't have to do anything
for perception remember most of her idea
of perception starts with the fact that
the user or the perceiver gets
information from the distal stimulus
does something on the proximal stimulus
generates a percept and dependent on the
motivations or dependent on the
expectations and context this percept is
assigned a meaning which means that in
this case up till now the theory
suggests that the user does something on
to the incoming stimulus and based on
that a meaning is generated contrary to
this view a theory of perception was
presented by JJ Gibson which is called
the theory of direct perception what
does the theory say this theory
basically goes ahead and says that the
world has a lot of information and we do
not need to do anything to that
information for perception to progress
so in in a way what Gigi Gibson goes
ahead this says is that perception is a
direct process and the environment that
we are in the environment that we are
perceiving has enough information onto
it enough information onto the onto the
proximal stimulus which is falling on
the retina so the proximal stimulus
which is part of the distal stimulus
which is falling on the retina has so
much information and the user has to
to actually go ahead and perceive he
doesn't have to make a per second
doesn't has to use context effect it
does it has to use some kind of a
building a process using or using Mars
method Mars theory of perception but the
environment on its own the user can sit
back and relax the environment provides
enough information for perception to
progress so the top-down process and
bottom-up process of perception believes
that the perceiver does something to the
proximal stimulus for perception to
proceed and so it is called the
constructivist approach it describes
people as adding to and distorting the
information in the proximal stimulus to
obtain a person so what the user does is
adds or subtracts information from the
proximal stimulus to generate a percept
which later on through the process of
what I'm talkin combine gives up the
meaning Gibson adopted an opposite view
to this to the connectivist approach and
gave up his idea of something called
direct perception his Gibson believes
that the perceiver as I said has nothing
to do or very little to doing perception
according to this view the light hitting
on the retina contains highly organized
information and the information that is
falling onto the eye onto the retina is
is is so great or is has so much
information or has so much bits of
information that the observer is not
required to do anything not to prove
whether Gibson was right whether
observer doesn't require to do anything
or another observer doesn't require any
kind of interpretation or any kind of
work on to the proximal stimulus to
generate the percept an experiment was
done to to prove this and this
experiment was done by someone called
Johnson in 1973 so Johnson
1973 he did an experiment he did an
experiment with light bulbs what was the
experiment so what he did what Johnson
really did was that he attached
lightbulbs to actors and so these actors
actually wore the light bulb so these
are two actors and they have light was
attached to them and so they are in two
different configuration can assume that
these are light balls and so when an
experiment like this was done these
actors were actually taken into a dark
room and in this dark room these actors
were asked to do several pose poses and
take several process do several acts the
observers who are observing this
particular people or these actors who
were wearing light bulb shirts and from
just from the way they acted just from
the movement of the light bulbs they
were able to perceive or they were able
to generate meaning or tell exactly what
was going on what was the act in doing
this was not the only amazing fact about
it what actors could also tell or what
observers could also tell from the
actors who were acting was whether this
actors were males and females and kind
of other specific stimulus it basically
means that with very least information
available from the environment with not
building any information actors by just
looking at observers by just looking at
the actors acting or displaying certain
forms or displaying certain acts they
were able not only detect who the actors
were or what are the act they were doing
but also the gender of the actor the
kind of
act they were doing the kind of movement
that they were doing and several other
features of it and so this particular
experiment really proved that we really
do not need a lot of information
processing for perception to takes place
but there isn't Cavett to the Gipson
entity it's not always correct the
explanation which has been provided is
that the bottom-up and top-down
processes actually allow cognitive
structures to see what the perception is
whereas the Gibson in view actually
tells you to act in certain ways to
adapt that information and act in
certain ways so this is the difference
between the Gibson in view and the view
of the bottom-up and top-down processes
so basically what Gibson design or
Gibson Theory comes up and says that he
developed the Gibson developed his
theory of direct perception when he was
training World War two pilots and what
he realized or he gave the concept of
optic flow if you look at the stimulus
here
what he did was and I mean a number of
experiments with pilots who were taking
training or who were going ahead and
landing planes what Gibson explained
that the pilot when he sees information
when he sees out of his windshield he
gets enough information from the
environment which is approaching him the
texture the structure the kind of
movement which is there the ground
movement the ground color all these
information was enough for to tell the
pilot of how to land the plane and so
what Gibson proposed is that the idea of
something called optic flows or visual
arrays and as you can see here this is a
pilot who's landing and when he's
landing just before landing he sees all
this information about texture structure
kind of relative speed for example
things which are closer to the pilot
will move at higher speeds than the then
things which are far away and these kind
of informations which the pilot gets is
enough for him to land the plane he
should not be or he need not be
concentrating on information which is
really providing by his
display system and so that is where he
gave this idea of optic flow there so
the arrow in this particular thing
represent perceived movement the parent
motion of clouds ground a sec traffic
respect to the pilot now there is a
texture of the motion namely near as
things will appear faster and and
directions in which object seems to move
upward opposite depends on the angle of
plane and movement and so this
particular example was one of the best
example which gives some use to propose
the idea that there is something called
direct perception the observer doesn't
need too much information the observer
doesn't need to work on the information
which is being which is being presented
to him the environment presents a lot of
information to him and that information
the object the observer only has to
understand that information not even
make meaning out of it and just follow
that information and that is what
Gibson's idea of perception direct
perception was was there so what Gibson
says is that the information that is
available from the environment for the
observer exists in an animal environment
ecosystem so basically the environment
process provides some information to the
animal and the animal provides certain
kind of cognitive structures or selects
which information from the environment
to take to take and based on these two
kinds of interactions the perception
progresses so the animal decides the
animal only has to decide what
information to take from the environment
and this decision process is the core of
perception whereas the environment on
its own can provide a lot of information
and this decision process is the main
key to act actually any kind of
perception according to Gibson Yin views
now for Gibson the central question of
perception is not how we make an
interpreter stimulus array but how we
see and navigate among real things so
it's what Gibson believes is it's all
about functions is not important to
study in terms of perception of how and
what we interpret from stimulus
what a particular stimulus really means
that's not important what really
important is is known that an object is
there how do we navigate through it so
navigation in the environment is more
important than having any percept then
realizing or then understanding what the
percept really means so the basic idea
of Gibson in view is to understand what
the environment how to navigate the
environment rather than knowing what the
environment has now important idea of
Gibson in theory is the information
available in an organism exists not
merely in the environment but in the nmi
environment in an animal ecosystem as I
was just explaining to you what really
happens is that the job of the animal
here the job of the person who is
perceiving here is to decide what to
take in from the percept which is
available what he has to do is that the
environment gives enough of information
to the person the person only has to
decide what information to take and what
information not to take and concept
which is related to Gibson in theory or
the gift running idea of perception is
the concept of affordance now what
really it means is that organisms
directly perceived shape or whole object
and then objects gives have something
called an affordance now what are
affordance really means is that an
object which you are perceiving it
directs you to do certain act on it and
that is called an affordance
for example think of a chair now when
you look at a chair or when you think of
a chair the idea that the chair gives to
you the affordance that the chair gives
to you is sitting similarly if you look
at a button a light button now a light
button gives you the affordance to be
player to be pressed down or looking at
if you have printers at home and if you
think about the printers power button
the red light the green light which is
on it is off when it is off when you
press it it gives you the affordance to
be press down similarly doors handle or
the handle of glass doors
affordances or tell you what to do for
example if I have a handle like this it
gives you the affordance to put your
palm on to it and push whereas if I have
a handle like this it gives the
affordance to to basically hold it and
pull it towards yourself because this
requires you to wrapping your hand here
whereas this requires you to push it
with this hand now I think this is a
little bit confuse or people people
confuse with this kind of affordances or
affordances is what an object requires
or desires to be done so basically here
the definition is given as affordances
are the acts or behaviors permitted by
an object place or even for example
donuts to tell you two there is a round
or nap so it it the doorknob tells you
to grab it and to turn it down
similarly the affordance of a chair for
sitting or any other affordances of a
light ball to push through pushing or
light switches to be pushing it down or
affordances of door handles to be either
pulled or pushed and these are what
affordances are and so what
Gibson says is that objects in itself
affordances objects have affordances and
these affordances guide people's
behavior or what should be done and what
should not be done now the obvious
question is on one hand we have gifts
only in view and on the other hand we
have the bottom-up and top-down the
classic culpers approaches to perception
so is there a merger between them how
can this theory coexist what is the way
in which these theories can co-exist and
so a model was proposed by nicer in the
year 1976 which takes care of both the
theories which in which which adds up
both the theories to develop the final
percept and this history is called the
perceptual cycle
now what this theory or what this
approach goes ahead and tells is that
this perceptual cycle says there are the
integration of the get run in view and
the view of the classical approach to
perception combines to this way for
example the information of the world is
here and this is modified by cognitive
structures through perception that
forwards or directs exploration in
certain way and this will further
suggest what should be taken from the
environment or sample from the
environment so what does this theory
really say it says that the information
of the world whatever information
perceptual information is available into
this world that is modified or that is
being perceived or that gets perceived
perceived through a classical approach
of perception using different cognitive
structures so the visual cognitive
structures of perception rigid
structures of attention these structures
or higher-order structures leads to
perception either using the bottom of
the bottom-up or top-down approach it
leads to perception it leads to the
generation of the percept when the
percept is generated this percept leads
us to explore the environment to explore
to do certain acts when we do certain
acts when we do a particular act based
on the perception we present a behavior
we do a behavior they commit a behavior
and when I come behavior is there we
explore this exploration tells us what
is possible and what is not possible
once a behavior is done it directs which
type of behavior or which type of
actions can be done through the percept
so if I perceive something what that
particular thing when when behaving with
it what particular thing information
what behavior is allowed and what
behavior is now
and once we know what behavior is a lot
in what we were is not we feel this
again to the environment and from there
it again gets modified in this way so
basically information from the world is
actually gets modified and generates a
percept which is later on this percept
is tested in the environment in terms of
whether what behaviors are possible on
this percept what behaviors can disperse
percept generates and which of this
behavior allowable or not those behavior
which is allowable gets added up into
the information in the world of a
particular thing and whatever behavior
is not allowed is deleted here or is not
added and that information is also added
for example think of a tea cup know the
kind of a tea cup if you have there are
certain behaviors which is allowable
when we see it we see a tea cup and so
when we are looking at a tea cup then it
there is a certain orientation with it
and there are certain feature that it
allows example a lousy 50 to drink tea
but if we try to do something else with
it by moving the Gion in certain way
that is not allowed in certain behaviors
for example drinking is a behavior which
is allowed and other behaviors are using
this as something else or using this for
looking at things or doing something
else with it the behaviors are not
allowed and that is fed in environment
and based on that our perception is
improve or enrich so the next time we
deal with this cup or this kind of a
percept we know what is to be done and
what is to be not done and the
perception then becomes automatic the
whole of this perceptual processes is
done so as to make this whole idea of
perception automatic so that something
something what what is allowable is
accepted and what is not allowable is
not accepted and it goes into memory so
that a next time a new instance of this
behavior a new instance of this percept
is generated it doesn't take that much
time for perception
so basically perception in this section
of perception we looked at we started
with the classical approach where we
looked at some classical theories the
gestalt ideas of how what
perceptual organization is and how this
perceptual organization really works
what is the figure background concept
and how the figure and background
decides how what should what is to be
Percy what information is to be
generated and what is information is to
be left behind
no this idea was added on to some models
or added on to this there's some models
of perception we started up in the in
the next lecture on some models of
top-down processing we're sorry'
bottom-up processing where we looked at
models of template matching prototype
matching and so these models actually
showed how perception progress through a
data different data-driven approach in
which we look at basic stimulus features
is take this feature combine them
together and once we have combined all
these features together how does the
percept they will have out of it in this
particular lecture we looked at another
approach of perception in which the
data-driven approach is supported by
something called the theory divin
approach so perception is not only
taking in data from the environment
combining together and generating a
percept this perception process is also
held or is also influenced by something
called the expectation in and something
called the the context in which a
particular object is present and so
context and expectation adds on to the
data-driven approach to give you the
final perception for example if you look
at something which is new which you have
not looked before a part of information
which is coming to you you will look at
its shading you will look at the kind of
brightness the figure and all those
basic informations plus you will also
look at your memory to look at to
understand what is this particular thing
and based on that you combine these two
information together to generate this
idea of perception now in addition to
that there is an idea or there is a
whole theory of direct perception which
says that the object by itself by by
being where it is in the environment
offers you some information as to what
it is and where
is the place at which is present the
kind of information that is related when
you are looking at it it should also in
addition provides you what kind of
things you should do with it and you
should not do with it take an example
let's say we have UFO which has landed
somewhere and crash-landed somewhere so
when you see further obviously we have
some idea of what an UFO is so next time
when you see something which is circular
and flying which has landed somewhere
you both you're the turbulent process
and bottom-up process will work together
so when you go to the crash site you see
something which is circular something
which has which has stands on it from
where there is some kind of air movement
coming in where the fans would be on an
on an UFO where it would take off and
things like that so you combine these
informations together to to get the
concept or what our UFO is plus in terms
of the fact that in numerous movies you
have seen that a disc life shape which
has fans and which has doors and which
is of a certain way should look like a
UFO should be UFO that information
combined with you actually presently
seeing that particular UFO in a
particular environment combines together
to give the concept that this is a UFO
what direct perception would come in and
say that being where it is being where
the UFO is in in itself allows you to do
certain acts for example from your
experiences you you understand that
there is a door and so in the UFO where
from where people from other
environments will come so subtle
behavior you it will actually need you
doing that behavior and certain behavior
it will it will not allow you to do for
example if there is no door in in in and
you know or there is a crack in in in
the UFO it will give you an affordance
to basically go ahead and push it and
realize the door because most of the
movies don't tell you where is the door
in in the
so this affordance will tell you if the
crack is there from where the light is
coming on from the UFO you will have
this affordance that this is the door
and that itself should be enough for you
pushing in and your expectation of what
should be inside will guide you of what
you are going to see when you go inside
that place when you go inside that UFO
maybe Green man's coming in and then and
maybe taking you for a probe aerial
probe or whatever you wish to come up
with but this is how perception
progresses so the whole idea of
perception is what I have presented in
this lecture in the next lecture we will
go ahead and look at what is attention
and look at the theories of attention
thank you
[Music]
you